- Coming home, I think the best part
was seeing my family and friends.
And feeling this immense love and pride
and just feeling great to see them
and then just walking on
terra firma again, you know?
Not floating around but just
feeling the Earth beneath you,
that's a beautiful moment.
(light ethereal music)
I had those moments of, "Where am I?
"Am I in space, am I at
home, am I on the ground,
"how am I gonna move, how am I gonna eat?
"Am I able to throw food in
the air and go fly and get it?"
To walk on the beach was just
the most incredible thing.
When you look at the horizon,
it kind of helps regauge
your gyros in your inner ears
and it helps know exactly
what's up and down
and right and left.
Driving felt interesting
because you've been traveling
at 17,500 miles per hour.
And then you come back
and you get in your car
and you're like, "Oh, I'm
going 60 miles an hour, huh?”
"That's nothing.”
"I'm going a hundred miles an hour.”
"Oh, that's nothing."
It changes the way you think about speed.
I think food tasted better.
After eating the rehydrated vegetables
and the irradiated turkey,
coming home to a wonderful
meal and sharing it
and not having to go chase it
when it bounces off or
something, and you can pick it up
and you know it's coming to
your mouth, that's pretty cool.
If you wanna go to space, it
would be one of these things
that is transformative on
so many different levels.
I would tell future explorers
to make sure that when
you worked with others
that you work as a team,
you see all people as potential,
you know, space travelers together,
no matter what language they speak,
no matter what they look like,
no matter what food they eat,
and to know that we're
all in this together
and work hard and share the fun.